all right hello everyone how are you
guys doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day and my mouse is like
moving do you guys see that that's
weird hello everyone how are you guys
doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day and today we are here with
episode 11 of my moneymaking series a
series in which I show you guys a bunch
of different methods of which I know and
sometimes use to make money in game and
this is one that is pretty decent GP per
hour it is relatively low requirement I
would say um you do need some sort of a
cash deck however you don't need the
most it's not it's not too too involved
as far as cash goes and it's kind of
just like merching a little bit but not
exactly so let's get on into it and I
kind of explain to you guys what I do
all right so I recently found this
method through a site called GE tracker
they will be in the description down
below they are a sponsor of mine and
through one of the premium features I
was able to find insane margins on
making unfinished potions so I know that
this is something that has been in the
game for a while and is something that
is you know always decently profitable
however with this premium feature you
can you can sort by which ones have the
highest profit and I found that quarms
right now as you guys can see I was
buying them in the grand exchange have
an insane profit I'm going to put in my
pin you guys are not going to see that
but I want to go search and I went to
buy and sell one just to make sure so as
you guys can see whenever I bought all
the qums I bought them for
3469 well 3470 and as you can see I
could sell off the potions for about 500
GP more about about 450 460 so that is
an insane profit I ended up going and
buying 5,000 because I kind of want to
do this a lot I'm now going to go ahead
and go and do 500 of them and kind of
give you guys an idea of how long it
took me and how many you can expect to
make per hour and how much GP this will
end up being for you so from there it's
pretty simple there is one requirement
that you're going to need you're
obviously going to need cash to buy all
these and you're also going to need to
Bas the base level to clean that herb so
whatever the herb level is to clean
you're going to need that to also then
put it into a potion I do believe so
with qums this one requires 54 however
there are other things you can do such
as toad flx right now which you only
need level 30 and those you have an
approximate GP of 300 per one so the
approximate profit GP of 300 per one so
you can scale this down if you don't
have the level but I mean realistically
if you're 30 I'd recommend just going
ahead and getting 54 maybe 48 depending
on which one's the best of the time cuz
in the end you're going to want to level
your account anyways because you may
need the herbalore level for something
else and if you're going to end up
profiting off of it it is that much more
worth it
all right so if you guys are looking for
a tool to navigate the grand Exchange in
pretty much any facet of the game go
ahead and check out GE tracker they are
a sponsor of mine and they have a great
website I recently reached out to them
and I've been impressed with what they
have so one of the things that helped me
find the margins that I had to find for
this video was their unfinished potions
moneymaking method section of the
website whenever I go here as you can
see I can sort by which potions give me
the best profit whenever I buy and sell
one and if I make it into an unfinished
potion so this does save a lot of time
as you don't have to go through and find
yourself or at least buy and sell each
potion actually find what the best
profit is this is a premium feature
however there are non- premium features
and if you guys want to check out the
site feel free to down below all right
so in about 7 minutes time as you guys
could see I was able to make
458 potions so don't worry at all about
this dude this dude wants me to make a
fire get a fire cape for him I don't
know if it's a scam or not so I'm going
to tell him to just I can't do it I'm
sorry if you're watching this video
right now he said he's a sub that he
wants me to do his fire C I'm sorry man
I just can't do it but let's go ahead
and check out how much money we made so
I'm going to go ahead and buy one of
these Corum potions and then I'll
compare it to how much you know we spent
to initially get this all right so there
we go just sold off the Karm potions or
am currently selling them off I'm sure
they'll sell just because you need them
to do herblore and it's not that many
compared to however many you're going to
have to buy to do herblore so I'm sure
they'll sell but with that being said
what I was able to find was that I was
making about 400 GP profit on each one
of them which is n too bad at all which
means that in total I was making 1.5 or
1.6 mil per hour which is actually
insane all right so I found that I was
able to make about 1.6 mil an hour which
is absolutely insane I was making about
400 GP profit off of each potion that I
did which means by math that I make
about 4,000 potions an hour it's
definitely something is not afkable at
all because the potion inventory is
really quick and that's what allows you
to make 4,000 an hour it's something
that flies by relatively fast and it's
is nothing that you can take lightly so
you do have to pay attention however
with such low requirements and making
1.6 mil an hour it is definitely worth
it if you guys want to find out what the
best items are remember check out GE
tracker awesome sponsor and much love to
them um I did actually find after this
video the toll facts were up to 500 so I
could have done those but nonetheless
hope you guys enjoyed the video If you
guys did make sure to leave a like if
you guys have anything you want to tell
me comment it down below if you want to
see future money-making methods and just
progress videos and stuff like that as
soon as I go live make sure hit that sub
button check out the the Twitter in the
description I can't talk sorry and uh 07
helpers in game is a cool place to hang
but nonetheless hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace
[Music]
ho